hi I'm nimesh Patel I'm here to answer
the internet would you rather see
everything that has occurred in the
history of the world or everything that
is going to happen in the future easily
the future I don't give a [__] about the
past
[Laughter]
you know you're doomed to repeat it sort
of thing no no we already know if I
really want to know just read
I've done that in a while
I choose I openly choose not to yes can
you still go to your Barber if he is
very racist a thousand percent
racists give the best haircut
it's true if you went to a white racist
you'd be okay with that I mean like it
would be you I would be so racist I
would be racist I am racist to think a
white Barbara would not be able to give
me a proper fade
if I found one that did I'd like man you
are we are set in race relations
together
it'd be fun if you had to get one movie
quote tattooed on your body what would
it be
that's how you shoot from now on that's
how you shoot Will Smith says it's a
Martin Lawrence's character in uh bad
boys
right puts it right and puts it to
Johnny tapia's brain it's like that's
all you shoot
across the back big letters oh yeah no
right above
if you won 300 million dollars what are
the first three things you would buy uh
the sf90 Ferrari electric one an
apartment in dumbo uh overlooking the
water and that's it your money's gone
yes and then a driver for that apartment
so that because Dumbo is located in the
bricks this is isolated you big car guy
yeah you know I I just listened to
Freddie Gibbs on the way here and he's
talking about the electric Ferrari I was
like oh yeah that [__] is a fire ass car
sorry for that very honest answer guys
cocaine
would you switch your penis size with
your foot size
it'll make very inconvenient paints but
I'm pretty I'm pretty happy with where
I'm at right now you know it's got me
this far I think if my foot were going
in my wife we'd probably have a problem
there was a snail following you for the
rest of your life and if you touch it
you die how long could you survive
that's like it still moves like a snail
but it's like it's it's Out For Blood it
knows who you are it knows where you are
it's chasing after you it's still it can
get it's chasing you and it's trying to
touch you yes it's still but like it
it'll go to the airport it'll get on a
plane but it's still gonna move like a
snail so it's gonna take that's such a
crazy metaphor for death chasing you
death is just around the corner you
never know where it's going to be how
long would how long would you survive
and I'll survive this long man I don't
know if the snail's chasing me I feel
like death is just always around me and
I've been avoiding it pretty but pretty
well so yeah yeah Dodge a few bullets so
thank you for this dark reminder of my
mentality
everywhere I look this would be a
[__] snail
would you rather your dick shed its skin
like a snake or have it rattle like a
rattlesnake every time you move oh man
I was just trying to imagine what
reality my apartment would be like if my
dick move rattled every time
I I just like the comic uh the comedic
part of having a rattly ass dick
not tonight
shut that [__] off no yeah that would be
fine would you rather be hairless or
never be able to cut your hair
oh nah [__] alopecia dog that's Charlie
Villanueva [__] yeah I wanna I will grow
this hair to ends of the Earth man I
mean not 73 said hairless that's kind of
crazy that is wow I don't I mean I think
when you get down to
like 10 20 30 years of growth you might
be like I wish I chose the other way
yeah maybe you're gonna be disgusting I
guess I guess if you yeah like like
hairless is like yeah you're Charlie
building away but we make fun of you the
other is like you're a circus freak yes
you're right you know what I take it
back please strip me bald
would you rather have a good hand job oh
no from your grandmother or a bad hand
job from your grandmother
I'm sorry Bob I'm sorry she got tiny
little hands man
yeah I mean if I have if it has to
happen it's going to be good might as
well enjoy yourself might as well have a
good time also I can't imagine my
grandma wanted me to have a bad one
you're really thinking about her yeah
that's really what she would like you
get over with faster too like a bad hand
job like I mean yeah yeah but if it's so
fast you're like God damn Grandma you
[__] work that [__] that's a little
too much would you rather fight Mike
Tyson or sound like him for the rest of
your life easily sound like him for the
rest of my life yeah yeah no you think I
mean that might mean impact your career
though like
like so would being punched in the face
would you rather be a pig and be able to
orgasm for 30 minutes or be a lion and
be able to have sex 60 times a day
is the lion also coming yeah yeah
there's a good come
who wants to orgasm who wants to orgasm
for 30 minutes yeah it's a long [__]
time man like if I work like I can't
stand it for more than like
20 seconds if I after you come and then
my wife's going [__] like oh it's
gonna
I'm not doing that
60 times in and out baby
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on all the celebrities
you'd like to see and make sure you hit
the Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out